I sent a mining team to collapse the
cavern but they never reported back find
them and help them get it done after
that we can clean up what's left now
it's time for you to finish
them
hell
a
go
oh
round
St
h
please you have to finish it we were so
close just those last three support
beams and we'd have caved it in boom no
more ochers there 's no one left to help
just me and I'm spent get through the
ogres and you could do it alone though a
pickaxe to the support beams down there
will bring the whole place down smash
him and then run for your life just down
the hill shamaro lorga had one when we
ran the ogres followed him I I heard his
screams his pickaxe should be there I'd
give you mine but it's all I have to
defend myself if the ogres see me I I at
least want to go down
swinging all right take it if you come
back and I'm dead though I still want it
back I want to be buried with it it's
always brought me luck hope it does the
same for you for all of
us
go
d
C
you did it I couldn't believe it when I
heard the crash but you brought the
whole place down almost I searched
through the rubble was just about to
give up I'm glad I found you though